Se le conoce como "The Lucky Country",
el país afortunado.
Sol, increíbles playas,
una rica vida natural y muchos,
muchísimos recursos naturales
Así es Australia, el paraíso del surf y
también del cricket ese deporte
británico tan pausado que hasta parán
para comer y tomar el té.
Australia, amigos
de VisualPolitik, es un país tan
especial y tan único que el 80% de sus
plantas y animales no existen en ninguna
otra parte del mundo.
Fijaros si aquí todo es raro que,
de hecho, su animal más característico,
casi su emblema nacional,
el canguro no corre ni trota sino que
salta.
Ahora bien, su medio natural no sólo es
único
también es temible.
Australia tiene más
cosas que puedan matarnos que ningún
otro lugar.
Por ejemplo, las diez serpientes más
venenosas del mundo son de aquí, de
Australia.
¿No te parece suficiente? ¿Quieres más
pruebas de lo hostil que puede llegar a
ser el ecosistema australiano? Pues bien,
atentos a esos cuatro animales:
La araña de tela de embudo,
la medusa cofre,
el pulpo de anillos azules
y el pez piedra. Todos ellos
están en Australia y son los más
letales de su especie en el mundo.
Y, cuidado, porque hay más, mucho más.
Cocodrilos gigantes que llegan a pesar
más de 1.500 kilos o tiburones de
todos los tipos y tamaños. Y si los
animales aún no te parece suficiente,
no cantes victoria,
hay muchos, muchísimos más peligros
naturales de todos los tipos porque
Australia es una tierra seca, calurosa,
árida y climatológicamente muy
agresiva
Sin embargo, ninguna de estas cosas ha
impedido ni remotamente que Australia se
haya convertido en un sueño para
millones de personas que anhelan un
futuro mejor. Tampoco es tan raro,
fijaros qué lugares tan increíbles
podemos encontrar, esto es la Gold Coast:
Lo reconozco, amigos, a mi Australia también
ha cautivado
Pero, ojo, no sólo hablamos de la gente
corriente, en los últimos años este
país se ha convertido, también, en un imán
para los millonarios, para las grandes
fortunas ¿por qué? Para verlo vamos a
dejar a un lado los animales y vamos a
hablar de los negocios.
Cada día es más fácil moverse por el
mundo, hoy podemos llegar prácticamente
a cualquier lugar de forma rápida y
cómoda. Y además gracias a internet y a
todas las nuevas formas de comunicación
hoy podemos dirigir un negocio a miles
de kilómetros de distancia.
Fijaros cómo han cambiado las cosas en
relativamente poco tiempo:
Hace apenas 50 años
un viaje en avión entre Londres y Sidney
estaba repleto de escalas y no duraba
menos de tres días.
Hoy este trayecto se pueda hacer en
apenas doce horas, en un avión cómodo,
seguro y con una pantalla plana para
cada pasajero con cientos de películas
series y música.
Seguramente cosas así son las que han
hecho que hoy las grandes fortunas sean
más exigentes,
al fin y al cabo pueden elegir
fácilmente qué sitio prefieren para
vivir sin que esto afecte para nada
a sus negocios. Hoy los millonarios ya no
se conforman sólo con impuestos
atractivos, también quieren vivir en
lugares con calidad de vida, buenos
colegios, facilidad para hacer negocios y
seguridad, ojo, tanto física como jurídica.
Es decir, la seguridad que les permite
que sus ahorros estén a salvo de
cualquier déspota o la que les
garantiza que no van a terminar en la
cárcel por llevarse mal con algún político.
Y aquí, Australia tiene mucho que ofrecer.
Por un lado es la quinta economía más libre
del mundo; en este país es fácil, muy
fácil hacer negocios. Hay muchas
oportunidades, la justicia funciona bien,
tiene un sistema financiero muy competitivo
y en general las regulaciones son livianas.
Por otro lado es uno de los
países donde mejor se vive y donde más
servicios de calidad se pueden
encontrar, como hospitales, universidades
o colegios.
De hecho, sus grandes ciudades se sitúan,
año tras año, en los puestos más altos
en los rankings internacionales de
calidad de vida. Por ejemplo, Melbourne
lleva seis años consecutivos liderando
el ranking elaborado por The Economist
sobre las ciudades donde mejor se vive.
Fijaros que maravilla de sitio.
Y, por si fuese poco, en 2012 el país
aprobó un programa de puertas abiertas
para las grandes fortunas.
Todos aquellos
millonario que inviertan unos tres
millones y medio de dólares americanos
obtienen la residencia permanente. Para
los millonarios que no tengan tanta
liquidez hay otra programa que sólo
requiere invertir unos 750.000 dólares;
en este caso hay algunas restricciones
pero en poco tiempo se puede acceder
también a la residencia permanente o de
Calidad de vida, facilidad para
hacer negocios y puertas abiertas
¿sabéis cuál ha sido el resultado?
Atentos porque es sorprendente.
Tanto en 2015 como en 2016 Australia ha sido el
país del mundo al que más millonarios
se han trasladado, más incluso que a
Estados Unidos. En concreto, en 2016,
11 mil millonarios se trasladaron a este
lugar. Una cifra increíble para un país
cuya población no llega a los 25
millones de habitantes, aproximadamente
la mitad de España. Y la verdad puede
que este sea el mejor ejemplo de la
locomotora imparable que es hoy la
economía australiana.
Cuando llegas a Australia, tienes la
sensación de haber llegado a una
versión mejorada de Estados Unidos.
Me explico, en general las ciudades y los
modelos de sociedad de ambos
países son relativamente similares.
Australia por tener, tiene incluso su
propia Washington, es decir una capital
levantada por y para el poder político.
Porque muchas veces se olvida pero la
capital de Australia no es Sidney ni es
Melbourne, es Canberra.
La verdad es que los propios
australianos podrían pasar a primera
vista por estadounidenses
si no fuese porque conducen por la
izquierda, beben té y adornan los
espacios públicos con estatuas de la
Reina Victoria. Sí, recordad que
Australia
formalmente es una monarquía y su actual
reina es Isabel segunda.
Pues bien, la cuestión es que a pesar de
las similitudes Australia es un país más
seguro, más limpio, más moderno,
más cosmopolita, más próspero, e incluso los
australianos son mayoritariamente más
ricos que los estadounidenses.
Ahora ya sabéis porque
digo lo de versión mejorada.
Por lo general, en los medios de comunicación
se habla poco de Australia, pero este
país lleva, atentos, 26 años sin conocer
lo que es una crisis.
La última vez que el país entró en
recesión Gorbachov ocupaba el poder en
la Unión Soviética. No está mal ¿verdad?
Ni crisis financiera, ni crisis de las puntocom,
ni de las materias primas, ni desempleo...
Nada de nada ¿el resultado? Con tan sólo
24 millones de habitantes su economía
ya es tan grande como la de toda Rusia.
Y, además, es un caso curioso del
que nos conviene tomar nota.
Australia es un país muy dependiente de
las materias primas que suponen, por
ejemplo, más de la mitad de todas sus
exportaciones.
Pues bien, cuando el precio de las
materias primas se vino abajo
todo parecía apuntar a que Australia
seguiría el camino de economías en
crisis como Rusia, Brasil, Ecuador, Arabia
Saudita...
Vamos, que los tiempos de alegría
llegarían a su fin. Sin embargo nada de
esto ocurrió, aquí a diferencia de
prácticamente al resto de países
productores, la crisis de las
materias primas pasó sin pena ni gloria.
Pero... ¿Qué hace que este país parezca
casi invulnerable a cualquier crisis?
Vayamos a verlo.
A los que nos seguís regularmente,
ya sabéis que en VisualPolitik solemos
decir eso de "buenas políticas, buenos resultados".
Pues eso es, precisamente, lo
que ha hecho Australia durante las
últimas décadas: reformas para mejorar.
Los cambios han sido muchos, así que
vamos a enumerar sólo los más
importantes.
En primer lugar, sus gobiernos
apostaron por abrir la economía al
comercio internacional, eliminando la
mayor parte de aranceles. Hoy el país es
un firme defensor de los acuerdos de
libre comercio.
En segundo lugar, a principios de los 90
el gobierno laborista de Paul Keating puso
definitivamente en marcha un modelo
de pensiones conocido como Superannuation
que está basado en la capitalización,
un modelo bastante similar al de chile
aunque desde mi punto de vista bastante
mejor por funcionar con más libertad.
El resultado ha sido impresionante,
el programa ha permitido generar grandes
cantidades de ahorros que han sido
invertidas en la economía productiva
Además, todo este inmenso volumen de
ahorro ha impulsado la industria
financiera.
Por ejemplo, Australia es ya uno de los
mercados más importantes de fondos de
inversión y no sólo eso:
En tercer lugar, muy importante también, en 1995 se
lanzó la Política Nacional de Competencia,
con el fin de reducir el
intervencionismo público en muchos sectores.
Este programa consiguió eliminar,
atentos, casi dos mil normas y leyes que
restringían la competencia.
Además, se puso en marcha un ambicioso
plan de privatizaciones y la eliminación
de monopolios públicos, por ejemplo,
Qantas, que os prometo es mi aerolínea
favorita.
Si tenéis la oportunidad no lo penséis,
Qantas,  y no es un anuncio.
Una, dos, tres y junto a todo ello
estabilidad presupuestaria, flexibilidad
laboral, etcétera, etcétera.
¿El resultado?
25 años sin recesiones, pleno empleo en la
economía, un salario medio de más de
5.000 dólares al mes y muchísima
inversión extranjera. No está mal
¿verdad?
Ahora ya podemos saber que cuando un
gobierno culpa de la crisis a los
precios de la materia prima es porque
sencillamente no ha hecho los deberes
¡Ah! Qué no se me olvide, en los últimos
tiempos
Australia está cuajando muy buenas
relaciones con Israel un país al que le
acaba de tocar la lotería de los
recursos naturales
Si quieres descubrir cómo Israel está
a punto de convertirse en toda una potencia
energética
no te pierdas este vídeo donde te lo
contamos con todo detalle.
Las implicaciones en Oriente Medio pueden ser
enormes.
Bueno, y tú ¿Cómo ves la cosas? ¿Acaso sueñas
como hago yo con pasar una temporada
recorriendo este fabuloso país? ¿Crees
que Australia será el nuevo Estados Unidos
del siglo XXI? No dudes en dejarnos
tu opinión en los comentarios,
nos ayuda mucho a saber cómo veis las
cosas y además siempre se abre debate.
Si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no dudes en darle a like y por supuesto no
te olvides de suscribirte a VisualPolitik
pulsando aquí para estar al
tanto de todos nuestros nuevos videos.
Pronto hablaremos más de Australia.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima